bon déjà bravo et merci d'avoir cliqué
sur cette vidéo on a essayé de mettre un
titre qui donnait envie mais clairement
c'était pas gagné on entend beaucoup
parler de la réforme des retraites en ce
moment et c'est vrai que c'est dur d'y
voir très clair du coup dans cette vidéo
on va voir très concrètement et le plus
clairement possible ce que propose le
gouvernement avec sa réforme mais aussi
pourquoi elle fait autant débat et donc
quels sont les contre propositions
notamment de ceux qui sont dans la rue
ces derniers jours et au passage cette
vidéo vous plaît n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à cette nouvelle chaîne Youtube
si jamais c'est pas encore le cas je
vous laisse vérifier alors déjà pourquoi
est-ce qu'on parle d'une réforme des
retraites en ce moment et bien parce que
le gouvernement a présenté début janvier
2023 une loi pour modifier le système
des retraites actuelles cette réforme
des retraites c'est une promesse de
longue date d'Emmanuel Macron il avait
déjà voulu réformer ce système de
retraite lors de son premier mandat plus
précisément en 2019 mais face à un très
gros mouvement de contestation dans la
rue que ça avait déclenché et puis
ensuite face la crise de sanitaire du
covid et bien il avait choisi de
reporter sa réforme et voilà qu'on est
donc reparti pour un tour aujourd'hui et
pour bien comprendre faisons déjà un
petit point très rapide sur le système
actuel des retraites petit schéma pour
essayer d'y voir plus clair les
retraites aujourd'hui en France
fonctionnent de manière collective
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde finance
la retraite de tout le monde donc si
vous travaillez et bien tous les mois de
l'argent et prélever sur votre salaire
et votre entreprise par ailleurs verse
aussi une partie cet argent c'est donc
ce que l'on appelle des cotisations et
elles vont directement dans ce que l'on
appelle les caisses de retraite tout cet
argent qui est prélevé va donc dans une
sorte de pot commun mais ce pot commun
c'est pas le pot commun d'un cadeau
d'anniversaire pour un ami à vous c'est
donc un pot commun qui redistribuait
sous forme de pension de retraite au
retraités actuel c'est donc des pensions
de retraite versées chaque mois aux
différents retraités pour résumer donc
ce sont les personnes qui travaillent en
France qui financent et bien la retraite
des retraités le montant de cette
pension de des retraités elle est
calculée d'après plusieurs facteurs on
prend en compte le temps que vous avez
travaillé dans votre vie ainsi que votre
niveau de revenu et pour vous donner une
idée en 2020 la pension moyenne d'un
retraité était d'environ 1400 euros net
par mois alors c'est une moyenne mais ça
cache des inégalités parfois très
importantes donc là vous allez me dire
ok mais du coup pourquoi est-ce que le
gouvernement veut changer ce système de
retraite et bien la première raison qui
est avancée c'est la question du
financement de ces retraites en gros
comme on vient de le voir aujourd'hui le
système de retraite fonctionne de
manière collective les retraites sont
donc financées par les gens qui
travaillent le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a un déséquilibre
entre le nombre de retraités d'un côté
et le nombre de salariés qui payent pour
ses retraites de l'autre côté ce
déséquilibre il se creuse de plus en
plus notamment en raison de
vieillissement de la population on va
donc se retrouver avec moins de gens qui
travaillent et plus de gens à la
retraite autre dis donc pas assez de
gens qui financent et plus de personnes
qui ont besoin de ces retraites deuxième
argument avancé par le gouvernement pour
cette réforme des retraites Emmanuel
Macron veut rendre le système des
retraites plus simples et plus lisible
en fait aujourd'hui il existe pas moins
de 42 régimes de retraite différents
alors je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails des 42 régimes différents mais
faut savoir que parmi ces 42 régimes il
y a ce que l'on appelle 11 régimes
spéciaux qui concernent par exemple les
avocats les employés de la SNCF de la
RATP ou encore les fonctionnaires donc
les personnes qui travaillent pour
l'État et ces régimes spéciaux en gros
ils permettent à certains métiers
certaines professions de partir bien
plus tôt à la retraite ou alors d'avoir
un calcul différent de leur pension de
retraite et c'est un mode de
fonctionnement qui fait débat depuis pas
mal d'années car certains régimes du
coup sont jugés par le gouvernement plus
avantageux que d'autres ce qui crée donc
selon le gouvernement certaines
inégalités alors du coup vous allez me
dire que contient cette réforme des
retraites portées par le gouvernement et
bien le premier changement c'est donc
l'âge de départ à la retraite lui-même
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que l'âge de
la retraite c'est officiellement 62 ans
et le gouvernement veut le relever à 64
ans d'ici 2030 en l’allongeant en fait
progressivement un petit peu chaque
année alors petite précision tout de
même je dis officiellement c'est 62 ans
car 62 ans en fait aujourd'hui c'est
l'âge légal mais là je légale ça ne veut
pas forcément dire que vous toucherez la
pension de retraite maximum qui vous est
dû si vous partez à 62 ans en réalité en
fait une fois cet âge légal atteint il
faut surtout avoir travaillé une durée
minimum obligatoire et donc avoir versé
des cotisations pendant une certaine
durée pour avoir droit au montant
maximum de votre retraite mais par
exemple si vous avez été au chômage
pendant un certain temps ou alors que
vous avez commencé à travailler
tardivement dans votre vie et bien c'est
possible que vous soyez obligé de
travailler au-delà de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite bref pour résumer
et j'en suis conscient c'est un petit
peu technique mais quand le gouvernement
français propose de passer de 62 ans à
64 ans ça veut dire qu'il veut en fait
allonger l'âge légal de travail minimum
pour partir avec une pension de retraite
maximum alors maintenant quel est
l'objectif du gouvernement en passant de
62 ans à 64 ans l'objectif principal
c'est une question donc de financement
de ces retraites vous la fait courte le
gouvernement espère qu'en reculant comme
ça là je l'égal de départ à la retraite
et bien les personnes travaillent plus
longtemps donc qui est davantage de
personnes qui travaillent et donc
davantage de personnes qui cotisent
tandis que de l'autre côté et bien les
gens partent à la retraite plus tard
puisque là je gagne est plus tard donc
il y a moins de personnes à la retraite
et donc il y a moins de retraite aussi à
payer chaque année deuxième changement
assez évident concernant cette réforme
des retraites c'est donc sur la question
des régimes spéciaux dont je vous
parlais à l'instant le gouvernement veut
donc supprimer ces régimes spéciaux les
métiers concernés par ces suppressions
seront donc affiliés au régime classique
avec l'augmentation de l'âge légal de
départ alors à noter tout de même que
certains régimes vont continuer à
exister dans le cas où cette réforme
passe c'est le cas notamment du régime
des avocats des marins ou encore des
employés de l'Opéra de Paris et de la
Comédie française par exemple alors
avant de voir ce qui fait débat et les
contre-propositions le dernier
changement qui est porté par le
gouvernement il concerne le montant même
de ses pensions de retraite donc de ces
sommes d'argent qui sont versées chaque
mois au retraité comme je le disais ce
montant des pensions de retraite il est
calculé en fait par rapport à votre
temps de travail et par rapport à vos
revenus chaque montant est donc
personnalisé selon la situation de
chaque personne je vous avais gagné
beaucoup d'argent lors de votre vie que
vous allez travailler longtemps votre
montant de pension de retraite sera plus
élevé que quelqu'un qui a été par
exemple au SMIC pendant toute sa vie
alors vous avez peut-être entendu parler
dans les médias que cette réforme
voulait mettre en place un minimum
retraite à 1200 euros
en réalité en fait ce minimum retraite
c'est un montant brut donc avant divers
prélèvements et impôts qui sont retirés
obligatoires en réalité cette pension
minimum qui est donc proposée par le
gouvernement elle est plutôt aux
alentours des 1000 euros par mois et à
noter au passage là-dessus que le
gouvernement souhaite que cette pension
minimale soit appliquée y compris pour
les retraités actuels allez reste
quelques minutes ne craquez pas
maintenant ce serait dommage on va voir
maintenant ensemble pourquoi ce projet
est critiqué et donc pourquoi est-ce que
autant de grève et de manifestations se
déroulent en France ces derniers jours
histoire donc que vous puissiez vous
faire un avis sur cette réforme ainsi
que sur ces contre-propositions alors
évidemment première chose qui motive
certains grévistes c'est la fin des
régimes spéciaux un certain nombre de
personnes forcément si opposent parce
que ce serait la fin de régime parfois
avantageux pour les salariés ce qui fait
par exemple donc que les cheminots sont
aussi nombreux dans la rue en ce moment
mais le reproche que l'on entend le plus
souvent concernant ce projet c'est donc
cette question de report de de départ à
la retraite en fait les opposants à la
réforme mettent en avant le fait qu'il
est très difficile pour les personnes de
plus de 60 ans actuellement de trouver
un emploi ou alors de poursuivre leur
travail actuel s'il est trop épuisant en
France en 2021 seul un tiers des
personnes
âgées de 60 à 60 ans travaillé
actuellement pour plein de raisons
différentes autrement dit et bien les
opposants c'est très réforme jusque
repousser l'âge légal à la retraite ne
va pas changer grand chose les gens ne
travailleront pas davantage simplement
il y a un risque d'avoir davantage de
personnes âgées au chômage par ailleurs
au-delà de ça je le disais certains
métiers sont plus épuisants que d'autres
et quasiment impossible à effectuer
passer un certain âge il sera donc
difficile pour certaines personnes de
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans et certains
n'auront donc pas d'autre choix que
d'arrêter dès que possible et ce donc
même si leur montant de retraite ne sera
pas à son niveau maximum alors je le
disais repousser l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite c'est la mesure principal de
cette réforme portée par le gouvernement
c'est une mesure qui est portée pour des
raisons économiques pour assurer une
forme d'équilibre dans ce système des
retraites mais c'est donc une mesure qui
est critiquée puisque certains juges
qu'il y a des alternatives qui sont
beaucoup plus justes pour les Français
la première alternative qui est portée
par certains économistes ce serait
plutôt d'augmenter un petit peu les
cotisations de retraite autrement dit
donc c'est somme qui sont prélevées sur
les salaires ou alors chez les
entreprises pour aller dans ce fameux
pot commun de caisse des retraites
là-dessus le gouvernement a répondu en
disant qu'il était opposé à l'idée
d'augmenter comme ça les cotisations que
ce soit pour les salariés ce qui
pourrait être avoir un impact sur leur
pouvoir d'achat à un instant T ou alors
du côté des entreprises qu'il refuse
donc de mettre en place deuxième
alternative qui est porté par certains
ce serait de faire contribuer les
retraités eux-mêmes au système des
retraites par exemple on supprimant le
fait que les pensions de retraite
suivent la hausse des prix ou alors en
augmentant tout simplement les impôts
des traiter et l'un des arguments de
ceux qui sont favorables à cette
solution c'est de dire que aujourd'hui
et bien le niveau de vie des retraités
et parfois supérieur à celui des actifs
donc à ceux qui travaillent et donc
faire contribuer les personnes
retraitées pourraient être une solution
et là-dessus c'est intéressant de noter
qu'il y a eu un changement parce qu'en
fait en 2017 Emmanuel Macron y était
plutôt favorable aujourd'hui il n'y ait
pas favorable car il estime que ce n'est
pas juste de faire payer les retraités
alors qu'ils ont travaillé déjà toute
leur vie pour leur retraite enfin
dernière alternative qu'on peut noter
c'est peut-être celle qui revient le
plus ces derniers jours et qu'on entend
le plus notamment dans le cadre des
manifestations et des grèves ce serait
le fait de mettre à contribution les
plus riches français pour financer ses
retraites alors c'est une mesure qui est
portée principalement par les plus
grands partis de gauche aujourd'hui
qu'estime que en taxant davantage et
bien les plus hauts revenus les
personnes les plus riches ou alors
éventuellement les super profits de
certaines entreprises qui ont des
profits records ces de moi et bien le
déficit actuel des retraites pourrait
être comblée et donc les retraites des
Français pourraient être financées voilà
donc pour la réforme portée par le
gouvernement et les alternatives
principales aussi qui sont proposés en
tout cas j'aime cette vidéo vous a
permis d'y voir plus clair pensez à vous
abonner il faut savoir que vous êtes une
minorité d'abonnés à cette nouvelle
chaîne Youtube que on a créé donc en
plus de la chaîne des actus du jour pour
publier nos interviews nos décryptages
mais aussi nos reportages qui viennent
dans les prochains jours du coup
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour nous
soutenir jamais c'est pas encore le cas
ça nous aide beaucoup rendez-vous aussi
sur Instagram dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains jours on va
suivre notamment les manifestations qui
se déroulent en ce moment on fera aussi
beaucoup de Live notamment sur notre
compte TikTok pour suivre les
manifestations directement en direct
pensez donc à vous abonner aussi à tout
ça mais c'est pas encore le cas en tout
cas la réforme est débattue à partir du
6 février à l'Assemblée nationale on
suivra tout ça prenez soin de vous
prenez soin de vos proches et on se dit
à très vite